bueno no solo las afueras de ese lugar
sino a lo largo de todo el recorrido la
gente se fue acercando incluso la propia
autopista los puentes de las autopistas
para saludar el paso del féretro que
llevaba al cuerpo de diego armando
maradona saludando dando vítores lo
mismo que estuvimos viendo a lo largo
del día miércoles a lo largo de este día
jueves específicamente aquí el día
jueves en la plaza de mayo ocurrió a lo
largo de todo este recorrido y también
allí en el ingreso del cementerio es un
cementerio privado que se llama jardín
bellavista y efectivamente ya hasta ahí
fue que permitió la familia que llegarán
los medios ya no ingresar bastante se
podría decir que la familia finalmente
accedió a abrir con lo que fue este
velatorio público que se hizo en la casa
rosada- sí con un límite de tiempo que
impusieron pero hasta ahí llegó ya la
parte del entierro del funeral es algo
que la familia pretende hacer a puertas
cerradas natal estábamos viendo imágenes
de como su cuerpo ya está en el
cementerio donde será enterrado con sus
cuál era la relación de maradona con su
familia
bueno aquí específicamente con sus
padres además se queda bastante claro
que la relación era muy cercana y por
eso también la familia tiene claro que
diego armando maradona quiere estar en
el mismo lugar
siempre hablo muy bien de su cercanía
con sus padres don diego doña tota la
madre una figura muy importante en la
vida de maradona cuanto ellos lo
apoyaron y lo acompañaron también para
que pudiera empezar y luego desarrollar
y crecer en su carrera futbolística ya
desde niño empezar de que eran ocho
hermanos y no era algo fácil en una
familia muy pobre vivían en villa
fiorito un barrio popular pobre de
casillas aquí en buenos aires y ahí fue
un esfuerzo también para la familia esos
primeros años especialmente para los
padres y por eso digo armando maradona
siempre estuvo agradecido a esa figura
paterna y materna
natalia vimos también una convocatoria
masiva en el velorio y también en el
cortejo fúnebre esto habla mucho de la
relación de argentina con el fútbol
habla de la relación de argentina con el
fútbol sin dudas pero sobre todo esta
relación específica con la figura de
diego armando maradona que sin duda se
trató de un futbolista excepcional no
solo excepcional por sus cualidades en
la cancha sino excepcional como
personalidad de una persona que no
respondía al común denominador ni de los
futbolistas ni en general de las figuras
públicas una personalidad muy fuerte que
imponía a su visión que salía decir las
cosas que pensaba que era controversial
que se sabía controversial y lo exponía
muchas veces superado por el propio
personaje algo que muchas veces él mismo
reconocía y una figura que alimentó
mucho el mito de sí mismo el mito del
fútbol y del futbolista argentino y
alimentó la cultura de este país
natalio muchas gracias por su informe
desde buenos aires nosotros más adelante
estaremos al tanto